foreign
favorite quotes comes from one of my
all-time favorite people Teddy Roosevelt
I I have the text of Roosevelt's man in
the arena speech hanging on the wall in
my office and as that great man observed
it is not the critic who counts it's not
the man who points out how the strong
man stumbles or where the doer of Deeds
could have done better the credit
belongs to the man who was actually in
the arena it's better to try and fail
while daring greatly than to never try
or to achieve anything at all so uh so
that you'll never know either Victory or
defeat I'm paraphrasing now but that's
that's the general idea and it's a
speech that came to mind on Thursday
with news that Elon musk's new rocket
exploded after successfully lifting off
from the launch
Starship is the largest most powerful
rocket ever built it's a staggering 400
feet long with 16.5 million pounds of
thrust essentially it's a skyscraper
designed to go into deep space
eventually musk wants to use the rocket
to send manned missions to the Moon to
Mars out farther into interplanetary
space The Vessel will be able to hold a
hundred people on each Mission along
with all the supplies and Fuel and
everything else that they'll need but it
requires a lot of trial and error to
achieve something of this magnitude
um no intelligent person expects that
SpaceX would be able to build Starship
and then send it off to Mars on the
first try without any issues
things certainly didn't work that
smoothly in the early days of NASA or
even in the later days of NASA but we
are surrounded with lots of very
unintelligent people who are seemingly
proud of their stupid stupidity and so
the Rockets malfunction a malfunction
that was very much expected and planned
for was met with um jeers and mockery
from the peanut gallery there were many
snide comments and laughing face emojis
leftists in particular were delighted
declaring that the explosion was some
sort of cosmic retribution for musk's
ideological crimes
the media joined in the celebration
laughing scornfully tossing subtle and
not so subtle Jabs here's Mika
Brzezinski on on Morning Joe turning the
snagness level up to a hundred listen
Friday it's Friday yes and Thursday it
was a very rough day for Elon Musk first
his three billion dollar rocket exploded
I'm gonna question that framing they get
a lot of great data out of that it
exploded
that was uh generally the tone from most
of the media and many of the snickering
idiots on social media never mind that
as Joe Scarborough actually correctly
pointed out uh the failure was not
really a failure SpaceX intentionally
triggered the rocket self-destruct
system after it veered off course and
the boosters failed to separate the
failure was a was a malfunction but
identifying the malfunctions is the
point of the exercise if you don't know
where your meat comes from then you
should change the way you buy meat today
you deserve meat that can you can
confidently serve to your family without
fear of what's in it you also deliver
deserve delicious meat with unmatched
quality that's why I personally
subscribe to good ranchers not only is
their meat fantastic but they're also
giving you free bacon for a year that's
a 240 value you can't beat that that's a
pound and a half of bacon in every box
that you're getting for free good
ranchers offers a price lock guarantee
which is just another way to beat
inflation their products are unlike any
other they're all natural Burgers USDA
prime steaks and better than organic
chicken have changed my standard for
great meat and it will change yours as
well you can use code walls for an extra
20 off your order and you should do that
right now today how can 100 American
meat get any better good ranchers has
donated over 1 million meals to local
food banks and they're just getting
started so head to goodrancers.com use
my code Walsh for twenty dollars off
your box free bacon great meat a secure
price and a bonus 20 off today you just
like I said you can't beat it that's
promo code Wall Street goodranchors.com
goodranchors.com American Meat delivered
you know when you're just starting out
in a career it's really difficult to
make yourself stand out from everybody
else but that is one of the most
important things standing out can be
tough especially when you're looking for
a job or when you're hiring looking to
find that application that really stands
out will get attention that's why you
need to check out zip recruiter zip
recruiter helps you find the most
qualified people for your roles and
they'll find them fast right now you can
try a zip recruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com Walsh zip recruiters
matching technology helps you find the
most qualified candidates for a wide
range of roles you see a candidate you
like you can easily send them a personal
invite so they're more likely to apply
their user-friendly dashboard makes it
easy to filter review and rate your
candidates all from one place let
ZipRecruiter help you find the best
people for all of your roles four to
five employers who post on ZipRecruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day you can see for yourself how this
works go to ziprecruiter.com waltz to
try ZipRecruiter for free again that's
ziprecruiter.com
w-a-l-s-h zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire again nobody expected the thing
to make it all the way to Mars on the
first go either way it was meant to
crash land uh they originally meant to
crash land in the Pacific
the only question was how far it would
get before it was destroyed ultimately
and made it 20 miles into space which is
pretty damned impressive for a vessel
the size of a 40-story building
it also means that they were able to
gather important information it will
make the next launch even more
successful which will in turn lead to
another launch more successful than that
one you have to walk before you can run
you have to get your rocket twice the
size of a Boeing triple seven into into
the stratosphere before you can get into
outer space
this is what science and Discovery are
supposed to look like this is how they
work Innovation is a series of failures
as long as you learn from them
the process is working exactly as it
should
you can't achieve anything worthwhile
without taking risks and if you take
risks you're guaranteed to fail at least
some of the time
anybody who takes risks and never fails
isn't really taking risks at all
this is what separates Risk Takers from
everybody else the risk taker has the
courage to fail
see many people in our culture they
don't understand this point because we
live in a world where so much of the
Innovation and Discovery has already
happened
the trials and errors those were all
suffered
before we were born and this is the
story of modern society We inherited a
world of luxury where everything comes
easy and quickly handed to us on a
silver platter
and we assume that it must have always
been this way we don't appreciate the
fact that there is a whole history of
work and suffering and failure and sweat
and tears and blood that is all baked
into this cake that we're currently
devouring ungratefully
if somebody comes along and tries to
push the boundaries tries to do
something new
we laugh because it looks absurd to us
because we are the most apathetic and
ungrateful generation of human beings to
ever exist on the planet
but but this isn't just about Elon Musk
and the rocket that exploded in general
I am just tired of the losers who have
never done anything never achieved
anything
never even tried to achieve anything and
yet who think that they're in a position
to criticize those who are actually in
the arena
there are the the doers of Deeds to use
Roosevelt's phrase and then there are
the pathetic scared little weaklings who
sit off to the side offering their
useless critiques
while contributing nothing of substance
to the world
this Dynamic has always existed
Roosevelt pointed to it over a century
ago but the difference is that we have
so many in that latter category now we
have so few doers of deeds and so many
doers of nothing
ironically the Achievers you know the
doers in the past they achieved so much
that they made it possible for people in
our time to do nothing to achieve
nothing and yet live in Comfort
the sidelines have never been so crowded
or so noisy
full of people who are terrified to step
foot onto the field but will laugh
nonetheless anybody else who stumbles
while doing what they would never do
and could never do
and a bunch of losers laughing at a guy
who literally builds spaceships
is just the most absurd and extreme
manifestation of this phenomenon it
certainly is not the only one
and that is why the entire do-nothing
peanut gallery is today canceled that'll
do it for this portion of shows and move
over to the members block hope to see
you there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]